the modern era everyone has a camera
we're always getting put on the Internet
have you guys notices us the Internet
yeah what is the Internet never
underestimate the power of navy blue ok
navy blue t-shirt navy blue jacket navy
blue coat hi these days you don't have
to spend a ton of money to have garments
to fit you well right obviously there's
certain things that are worth investment
but you could get away with a lot and so
you know if you're wearing something
that's sort of oversized and ill-fitting
in a picture you're gonna look bad in
the picture they tell me when we're
doing these videos not to wear white
because it washes washes you out is that
true in real life too I think that
pretty much any color looks good in
natural sunlight
but everyone looks good in a blue shirt
navy blue
yeah well no like a light blue shirt
like a blue öyster question oh yes that
color little so again if you know when
in doubt blue one thing that a guy is a
mutual friend of all of ours I think
Adam Rapoport always says is he's like
if you're having a picture taken at a
party say you're at a wedding instead of
going like that
I just eat just pretend you're doing
something so that your knots that
usually pretend that I'm running away
I've always been a fan of like a more
rep for Tosh kind of photograph anyway
like it feels too Posey then I don't
love it but you know like but when
you're talking about like for your
Facebook page or whatever like you need
to see your face so right there's a fine
line I think there's a reason why
street-style took off is because it's
natural we were doing any family we're
walking you know we're going to work is
how I like to say it I don't think I
think particularly good pictures but
when it's like you're walking going
somewhere fair game and that's why
sunglasses are super important to
totally but like yeah if you get me into
a studio and you want to take my picture
I'm just like I don't know what to do
yeah but you know how to walk down the
street you know how to walk from a car
into the fashion I haven't tripped over
myself in a while that's been documented
that's right well guys I think this is
really just all about the maternal power
of navy blue and the eternal power of
the candid photograph thank you very
much you're welcome to it uh guys
subscribe YouTube channel
leave a comment you
already know all this [ __ ] just do it
thank you bye